[Música]
enmanuel macon ganó en la segunda vuelta
de las elecciones presidenciales en
francia el mandatario alcanzó la
victoria con más del 58 por ciento de
los votos frente al 41 4% de su
contrincante marine lepén marco obtuvo
resultados muy favorecedores en la
ciudad de parís en su región urbana así
como en las grandes ciudades y en las
áreas más dinámicas de francia mientras
que el epen ganó en las zonas
periurbanas y también en las zonas
rurales la candidata de la extrema
derecha vio su derrota en las
presidenciales como una victoria al
lograr una votación histórica para su
formación política a continuación un
resumen de esta jornada electoral en
francia emmanuel macrón se queda en el
inicio el escrutinio da como ganador al
actual presidente sobre su rival la
ultraderechista marine le pen con 58
copas 54% se impuso en las
presidenciales aunque ganó el resultado
fue menor al de la contienda de 2017
cuando también se enfrentó al epen en su
discurso de victoria desde el campo de
marte anunció que buscará la unión de la
francia polarizada
reconoció que no todos sus votos fueron
de adhesión a sus políticas sino de
oposición a la que todos juntos
tendremos que trabajar por esa unidad
que será la única que nos permitirá
vivir más felices y enfrentar los retos
que nos esperan
los años que vienen no serán tranquilos
con toda seguridad pero sí serán años
históricos y todos juntos sabremos
escribirlos para nuestras generaciones
pese a su holgada victoria es consciente
de las críticas de su gobierno crisis
como las manifestaciones de los chalecos
amarillos el manejo de la pandemia y la
guerra en ucrania por eso anunció un
cambio de este próximo quinquenio
por todo esto quiero junto a todos
ustedes afrontar los próximos cinco años
esta nueva era no será la continuidad
del mandato que acaba de terminar
sino la invención colectiva de un nuevo
método para cinco años que serán mejores
al servicio de nuestro país y de nuestra
juventud de unas funciones
[Aplausos]
imagine lepén recibió el 41 46 %
interpretó a los resultados como una
victoria el resultado de esta noche
representa en sí mismo de todas maneras
una victoria sorprendente esta francia
tan olvidada nosotros no la olvidamos
estamos más determinados que nunca y
nuestra voluntad de ayudar a los
franceses es aún mayor además de
anunciar que sería oposición de macrón
llamó a votar masivamente las
legislativas para hacerse con el
parlamento esta noche lanzamos la gran
batalla electoral de las legislativas
[Aplausos]
librar esta batalla al lado del señor de
like con todos los que tuvieron la
valentía de oponerse al señor marco en
la segunda vuelta la extrema derecha
tuvo una votación sin precedentes en
estas elecciones aunque la abstención de
28 2 % fue la más alta desde la segunda
vuelta presidencial de 1969 bueno fue
una victoria para macrón pero como ya lo
decía el reportaje ahora la batalla
continúa las elecciones legislativas que
están previstas para el mes de junio
para decidir la gobernabilidad del
mandatario de los franceses el llamado a
participar lo hizo como lo veían ustedes
la candidata marine le pen veamos cómo
se configura entonces el panorama de
cara a las legislativas de mitad de año
una victoria para emmanuel ma chrome
pero es probable que las celebraciones
duren poco sus oponentes políticos ya se
están alineando para la próxima batalla
electoral las elecciones legislativas en
junio ese voto definirá la composición
del gobierno en el que confiara para
impulsar sus políticas con el apoyo de
aliados centristas el partido república
en marcha del presidente tiene una clara
mayoría en el parlamento saliente en el
extremo izquierdo francia insumisa tiene
sólo 17 diputados mientras que
agrupación nacional de marine lepén
tiene 8 los presidentes recién elegidos
suelen obtener una mayoría en la
asamblea nacional debido a la baja
participación general entre los
partidarios de los candidatos derrotados
pero una desafiante marín gp me está
instando a los votantes a asegurarse de
que haya un fuerte bloque de oposición
nos lanzamos esta noche la gran batalla
electoral de las legislativas lideraré
esta batalla con todos aquellos que
tuvieron el coraje de oponerse a manuel
macrón después de perder por poco en la
votación de la primera ronda el veterano
de extrema izquierda jean luc mélenchon
tienen los ojos puestos en un nuevo
objetivo
la tercera ronda comienza a esta noche
en los días 12 y 19 de junio al pedirles
que me elijan como su primer ministro de
hecho les estoy pidiendo que creen un
nuevo futuro para nuestro pueblo
los votantes también parecen ansiosos
por el cambio una nueva encuesta sugiere
que sólo uno de cada cinco quiere que
macros obtenga la mayoría con más de la
mitad a favor de una alianza que
bloquearía sus políticas a pesar de
tener el impulso detrás de ella le pen
se sintió amargamente decepcionada en
las elecciones regionales de junio
pasado cuando su partido no logró
quedarse con ninguna de las regiones
misión también ha tenido problemas para
ganar terreno a nivel local sobre los
verdes y los socialistas que ganaron
varias ciudades importantes incluidas
parís marsella y burdeos en las
elecciones municipales del 2020
bueno la reelección de manuel mckeown
como presidente de francia cuál va a ser
el panorama político y ese reto que
tiene para las legislativas es nuestro
tema de debate y de análisis hoy en el
programa y para analizar este tema hemos
invitado a guillem askari él es analista
político y periodista se encuentra en
las ciudades de parís en francia y aquí
en el estudio de france 24 se encuentra
con nosotros jump based él es director
del grupo de estudios de la democracia
de la facultad de estudios
internacionales políticos y urbanos de
la universidad del rosario que está en
la ciudad de bogotá en colombia ustedes
nuestros televidentes también pueden
participar en este debate con sus
comentarios y sus preguntas las pueden
hacer a través de nuestras redes
sociales no se encuentran en facebook en
instagram y en twitter estamos como
france24 bajo ese arroba santi logo que
es mi cuenta personal les recuerdo que
nuestra etiqueta es numeral el debate
efe 24 esperamos todos sus comentarios y
preguntas participen en este debate y
sean partícipes de la conversación
comienza entonces con nuestro invitado
en la ciudad de parís
de mascar y para preguntarle como punto
de partida del debate ya veíamos un
resumen de la jornada y de lo que puede
venir en términos políticos para francia
pero quiero conocer cuáles son sus
impresiones que le dejan esta jornada
electoral esta jornada democrática como
se espera de un país como francia y de
los resultados que han obtenido
buenas tardes santiago mire yo pienso
que el bueno que manuel macro es una
victoria una victoria clara una victoria
quizás diferente de 2017 pero como él lo
dijo es también una nueva era el lo que
esta jornada yo creo que fue una jornada
muy importante por francia muy
importante también por la juventud
quizás hubo una abstención y eso es un
dato importante pero hemos visto una
imagen de victoria de manuel macro y una
juventud y yo pienso que su discurso de
unos 15 minutos
tenía un impacto y eso tendrá
repercusión durante lo que se llama lo
que llamamos la tercera vuelta y aquí en
el estudio de france24 bienvenido al
programa también como punto de partida
sus impresiones que le deja esta jornada
electoral en francia bueno efectivamente
una victoria de manuel macro aunque es
bastante meta digamos por un poco más
incluso de lo que las encuestas dejaban
esperar
y lo que muestra que de cierto modo el
frente republicano esta alianza de todas
las fuerzas en contra de la extrema
derecha sigue funcionando aunque pues se
debilita cada vez más pero pues sigue
finalmente importando estas segundas
vueltas pero es cierto con una extrema
derecha que sube elección tras elección
y que trata de romper finalmente esta
barrera
lo que veíamos era una selección es
sumamente polarizada es un país muy
dividido en torno a el futuro que desean
los franceses prácticamente son como dos
miradas distintas de lo que quieren para
el país esa brecha se está cerrando poco
a poco esa grieta que hay entre los
franceses o estas elecciones ya ha
demostrado que sigue profundizándose y
yo no diría que el país es es polarizado
y está divididos y hay muchas fracturas
acá pero varias fracturas distintas y no
diría que está polarizado porque
entraría y lo vamos a ver para las
legislativas hay tres bloques no hay
como y eso que es también una
simplificación hay un bloque de extrema
derecha un bloque de centro adentro el
centro de la derecha hay un bloque de
izquierda cada uno que va que pesa un
tercio del electorado y es por eso que
estas legislativas van a ser muy
importantes y entre esos tres bloques
efectivamente hay muchos debates muchas
fracturas muchas divisiones que que se
vieron a lo largo de todo este mandato
de manuel macro y sobre todo para estas
presidenciales la izquierda estaba muy
fragmentada le costó consolidarse en un
solo movimiento para y enfrentar las
presidenciales le pregunto y james en la
ciudad de parís el desempeño a nivel
electoral del presidente macro no un
candidato muy distinto al que vimos hace
cinco años que recoge usted de ese
macrón de ese primer mandato cuando ganó
esa presidencia y el presidente actual
que se enfrentó a una reelección como lo
ve usted
bueno creo que el macro tuvo un
quinquenio que no es fácil como
presidente hay que decirlo la vuelva de
los chalecos amarillos la pandemia es un
fue un quinquenio muy difícil y no sólo
por o por francia pero también por otros
países y eso pienso que hay que tenerlo
en cuenta en un primer tiempo segundo yo
creo que bueno hizo lo que pudo hacer
con cierto unas canciones y una cuestión
central también la pérdida del poder
adquisitivo que es también una cuestión
que fue tratada y la gestión del medio
ambiente pues tan medioambiental que
también es muy importante yo pienso que
bueno en la diferencia entre el macro de
2017 y el de 2022 y de los años a venir
este que también
aprendió y lo dijo en su mensaje que
pensó de sus errores y que bueno es un
macrón que ahora también tiene una
postura también
europea muy grande en esos meses
en la unión europea y también
de vente a la sombra también es delante
está esta gran ucrania que está en
europa entonces es un macro diferente
que también ha conocido varios crisis y
pienso que le ha solventado bastante
bien ya ni active el estudio de france
24 impresiones del desempeño electoral
del presidente reelecto ya y le añade
una segunda parte de la pregunta y es la
otra cara de la moneda marine lepén cada
vez cosechando más votantes un
porcentaje creciente en las últimas
elecciones y muy representativo para
estas últimas elecciones en francia qué
significa este no sé si se pueda decir
que se está fortaleciendo más la extrema
derecha allí en francia o si simplemente
es un proceso natural como el desempeño
de un partido si se está fortaleciendo y
se está fortaleciendo a aprovechando un
contexto que le era bastante favorable
no este mandato difícil que hemos dicho
de de manuel macro aunque tuvo que
enfrentar la crisis de los tráficos
amarillos la pandemia bueno ahora la
inflación y los conflictos a las puertas
de europa es un contexto muy difícil y
evidentemente para marín de penn pues
esto permite capitalizar todos los
descontentos por lo demás ha seguido con
una una estrategia de normalización de
tratar de suavizar su imagen de
y tratar de ocultar un poco los
elementos más polémicos del programa de
la extrema derecha
y tuvo además el apoyo esta vez de otro
candidato de extrema derecha que parecía
más radical que ella de cierto modo
entonces esto esto lo ayudó y estas
elecciones por lo tanto eran bastante
favorables es fue un contexto realmente
bastante favorable para ella que
efectivamente la llevó a estos buenos
resultados desde la primera vuelta y
después pues capitalizó un poco más con
la conexión del sentimiento anti macrón
digamos que se genera en parte del
electorado francés por polémicas de sus
mandatos digamos pero entonces que le
falló si tenía un escenario tan
favorable un descontento general hacia
el mandatario en ciertos puntos y el
contexto internacional le jugaba a su
favor que le falló a esa candidatura le
falló primero no logró realmente reunir
a todo en la última kronish moody amos
no le le fue muy difícil llegar al
electorado de izquierda aunque macro un
digamos y allí se enfrascó en polémicas
con roddick menos aunque finalmente no
no no no permitió hacer esta síntesis
difícil desde luego con los descontentos
de izquierda y por eso hablaba de que no
es una polarización simple no hay el
juego fue difícil para ella
y de todos modos digamos que este frente
republicano sigue funcionado ha
funcionado hasta cierto punto y ya y
digamos pues eso la isla de cierto modo
además no logró mostrar digamos logró
mostrar una imagen quizás más tranquila
con que genera menos resistencia pero no
tanto una imagen digamos de gobernante
más más sólida no en el debate se vio
todavía un poco no no tan preparada
frente a y manuel macro ahí entraría yo
preguntarle a guillem tal vez lo que
falló ahí fue la figura del liderazgo el
liderazgo que puede representar marín de
pena hacia los ciudadanos del común y es
el liderazgo que ya ha venido
capitalizando macro no solamente en
francia sino también en europa
claro le falló esta postura de liderazgo
y también creo que hay que recordar
también que hubo también una una de sus
últimos últimos días últimos meses a una
una campaña que también
antes la primera vuelta se hablaba
también de la la proximidad entre entre
marie le pen y vladimir putin sobre su
postura también frente a la guerra en
ucrania creo que todo eso entró mucho en
el juego y también él
también el otro partido reconquista
también
era también los decepción decepcionados
de marine le pen entonces yo creo que
hay un nuevo panorama político entonces
es cierto que ella no no habrá aprovecho
y que no consiguió a reunir porque no
tenía la posibilidad de reunir y su
programa eran más
le faltaba le faltaba en sus puntos en
su programa sobre todo si hablamos de
europa relaciones de de biodiversidad si
habíamos de medio ambiente es una
persona que
una candidata que cree que creció pero
careció con una cólera creció con una
digamos no creció por por adicción
también creció también por una parte una
parte por por adicción pero por una
parte no también de unas personas que
estaban también contra emmanuel macro
pero que no estaban fuerza mente al de
acuerdo con cuando marín lópez quien soy
muy importante claro guillén y de cara a
esas elecciones parlamentarias que es
ahora el siguiente escenario político
que va a estar en controversia en
análisis en los próximos meses como
puede marie le pen capitalizar estos
resultados como puede fortalecerse ella
ya hizo un llamado a los ciudadanos a
votar en esas legislativas y hacer quien
encabece esa campaña para lograr la
mayor cantidad de escaños en las
legislativas como lo podría capitalizar
qué jugadas podría ser en términos
políticos qué chances tiene ella y su
formación para esas legislativas
como se hablaba antes hay tres bloques
hay el bloque el campo nacionalismo que
es el campo de marine le pen que es el
campo de reconquista con él el ex
periodista
que dice moore y ahí también nicolás de
contención también como también
candidato hay el bloque que también es
grande con una grande base que es el
bloque de desde el centro del centro y
ahí el bloque de la izquierda yo creo
que en esa elección en esa dinámica que
tiene y sobre todo por esta tercera
vuelta hay que ver el anclaje local y
cuenta mucho y también el
continuidad también del resultado de la
segunda vuelta yo pienso que que marín
lópez que ahora tiene 88 diputados
89 creo en la asamblea nacional es no
tiene no tiene fuerza mente la
posibilidad de cambiar con este bloque
yo no lo creo en las cosas
quizás cuando reconquistar y tener un
máximo pero no lo creo pero no tendrá
mayoría y hay que mirar sobre todo la
dinámica de sonic menor que desarrolló
bastante su anclaje local durante esos
últimos años hay entonces puede haber un
juego de piezas ya está usted de acuerdo
con este este rompecabezas que se
armaría de pronto para las
parlamentarias así es es un sistema muy
complicado el sena francés no dos
vueltas presidenciales dos vueltas
legislativas las legislativas son un
sistema mayoritario de dos vueltas y la
ventaja de makro es que está en el
centro entonces candidato macrista que
se quede en la segunda vuelta
normalmente gana porque pues lolol los
que están eliminados normalmente van
hacia él en contra del otro extremo
entre comillas no entonces tiene esta
gran ventaja de estar en el centro del
juego no pero le va a ser mucho más
difícil que la primera vez porque
efectivamente tenemos esta esta división
entre los entre los tres bloques ahí lo
que está clave es ver si en el en el
bloque de la extrema derecha va a haber
alianzas que es difícil porque entre
marín detenidos a segunda hora ha habido
muchos muchas tensiones entonces hay que
ver si logran ponerse de acuerdo va a
ser para ellos y en la izquierda también
muchas extensiones pero pues ya se están
hablando están tratando de armar un
bloque y eso va a ser clave para ver
cómo cómo van a funcionar esas
legislativas antes de pasar a analizar
los retos y lo que viene para francia
para estos siguientes cinco años de
mandato de manuel marco y quiero
terminar el análisis de estas elecciones
con el desempeño de la izquierda fueron
muy importantes para esta segunda vuelta
a dónde iban a ir esos esos candidatos
votos de esa izquierda como ya hemos
dicho aquí fragmentada que le costó
consolidarse un poco dentro de un solo
movimiento y unificarse un poco el
desempeño de la izquierda que deja qué
sabor deja la izquierda en estas en
estas elecciones
bueno una yo ni melón su es el es el
ganador a la izquierda de de todas esas
polémicas que hubo a la izquierda pero
un ganador que deja fracturas que deberá
ronco reza y va a ser muy difícil
reconstruir los partidos clásicos de la
izquierda han sido claramente derrotados
particularmente el partido socialista
los verdes también y acá hay que
reconstruir algo y ahí como se va a
reconstruir y para sobrevivir finalmente
en esta plana dorama cronista en el
centro y esta polarización con la
extrema derecha la izquierda necesita
realmente
organizarse y formar un bloque
con todas las fuerzas no y eso es lo que
lo que está en juego acá para la
izquierda en estas legislativo fueron en
cierta forma los protagonistas de estas
de estas elecciones de los mucho que
hablar quiero conocer la opinión de
guillén sobre este partido izquierda y
estas formaciones el desempeño que
tuvieron fueron muy relevantes ya lo
decía yo en cierta forma se robaron el
show
con los votos en un momento
sí
creo que estoy totalmente de acuerdo
creo que en la izquierda hubo o hubo una
dinámica una dinámica cuando hablamos
por ejemplo de histórico - o es una
dinámica muy importante que él hizo
entre 2017 y ahora 2022 hay que ver
también una fuerza muy importante en la
izquierda en esta elección es que en
2017 el partido comunista y bajo control
emerson y en 2022
presentaron su candidato a falla russel
que también a pesar de desde un
candidato por el partido comunista
vimos que que sonic ominoso hizo un
score muy importante y eso eso hay que
ver como como las fuerzas de la
izquierda se van a organizar entre entre
los verdes entre el partido comunista
entre johnny como nación para saber cómo
como también puede pueden ganar escaños
de qué forma se van deben organizar creo
que eso es una buena pregunta
ya lo veremos cómo serán los resultados
que arrojen esas elecciones
parlamentarias
paso ahora analizar lo que viene para
francia para estos cinco años que vienen
con mac o nuevamente como presidente es
un presidente que repite el reelecto
después de estos comicios y tiene una
ventaja jan y es que ya sabe gobernar ya
sabe y moverse en la acción
internacional ya sabe cómo actuar dentro
de la unión europea no es un candidato
que llega a la presidencia aprenderá el
funcionamiento del estado ya ya gobernar
a liderar ya viene con esa experiencia
pero que le falta a macrón que no le
funcionó en estos cinco años de mandato
que tiene que prestar atención para
estos cinco años que vienen que es tal
vez su tarea pendiente desde su punto de
vista tiene la ventaja de saber gobernar
tiene la desventaja de haber generado
muchos odios también no y él él es
consciente de esto lo ha dicho en su
discurso que va a tratar digamos de
resolver las fracturas que que se
presentaron
lo ha dicho entonces vamos a ver qué
tanto lo logra pero bueno con los más
pobres digamos macro no tiene siempre
esta imagen del tercer ser los ricos de
presidente de los ricos dice - jon pero
también de personaje elitista dice la
extrema derecha entonces ahí hay hay
fracturas sociales digamos sociológicas
fuerte hay una fractura también fuerte
con la francia rural digamos que se
presentó acá el macro es el candidato de
las grandes ciudades ha ganado en las
grandes ciudades pero pues en el mundo
rural es el mundo rural se siente un
poco abandonado la los servicios
públicos que no llegan bueno ahí hay un
desafío fuerte acá desde el cual también
es muy consciente otro otro frente de
resistencia que es muy interesante si
miramos eso en términos geopolíticos
los territorios de ultramar es muy
interesante lo que pasó acá no en la
primera vuelta ganó menos del candidato
de la izquierda con muy buena margen en
la segunda ganó el open es decir que
algo y ahí hubo reporte digamos de la
última kronish mo y uno de la última
kronish mo muy fuerte hay un problema
con los territorios de ultramar en
francia y lo tiene que resolver manuel
macro ese ese problema ya le doy la
palabra guillén para hablar sobre este
tema
será estos cinco años de presidencia de
marco se ha notado como una especie de
distanciamiento alejamiento de parís de
la metrópolis y estos territorios de
ultramar
cuál es el conflicto si en parte yo creo
que en parte también la gestión de la
pandemia ha sido muy difícil con estos
territorios de ultramar que además han
sido muy muy han sufrido mucho la
pandemia por por por y guadalope marsé
mica tuvieron unos picos de contagio muy
altos exactamente y ahí hubo mucha
resistencia a la política de vacunación
y de y de pase sanitario entonces
a la política muy dura que impuso macro
sobre este tema del pase sanitario fue
muy mal recibido por ejemplo en los
territorios de ultramar hay hay ayuda
hay unos temas que hay que retomar y
unos días un diálogo que hay que retomar
con esos territorios y guillem en la
ciudad de parís su perspectiva del
presidente macro en las deudas
pendientes y lo que puede mejorar para
esta segunda oportunidad cinco años más
en el poder
cinco años más en el poder hay hay
muchas muchas muchas cuestiones primero
la primera creo que hablamos mucho del
poder adquisitivo y como yo lo decía ese
es una muy importante por los franceses
lo vimos durante durante esas elecciones
y durante esa campaña creo que es eso es
muy importante
es verdad que no hay que ver si el
discurso de manuel macro también va a
pasar también en el medio rural porque
vimos también por los resultados que no
son los mismos entre las grandes
ciudades y también en las pequeñas
ciudades entonces hay que ver también
también por la reforma de las pensiones
creo que eso esto también es muy
esperado y hay que ver de qué forma que
manuel macrón también va a convencer
sobre la reforma de las pensiones
tuvimos durante el debate que era un
punto de tensión es un punto muy
importante y un punto de crispación en
la sociedad francesa porque hay
diferentes visiones sobre la reforma de
las pensiones otra otra cosa muy
importante en la reforma de todo el
sistema de salud los servicios públicos
que es muy importante es la arrogancia
la la la también la posibilidad también
de emanuel macrón también a saber cómo
también salir también de esta pandemia
que sigue también y donde hay también a
veces en unas partes también de europa
resaltó de de casos de covina entonces
todo eso creo que y además de la guerra
en ucrania todo eso en muy es muy
importante muy diferente a lo que
pudimos conocer en 2017 hits y están
bien por eso también que hablo de nueva
guerra porque entre 2017 y 2022 es un
mundo diferente soy no es el mundo
después kobe pero es un mundo donde
vamos a tener que hacer una refundación
y reinventar también una política dar
una otra dinámica pero dijo que en todo
caso no iba a ser una continuidad si en
este gobierno en este nuevo gobierno de
cinco años ya guillén lo decía el
escenario es completamente diferente y
la coyuntura es muy distinta a la que
había hace tres años este gobierno de
macrón guillem va a estar más enfocado
en ese tema económico en
potenciar la economía francesa
nuevamente el tema de pensiones que
usted ya lo decía que prácticamente fue
el tema que compró muchos o no que
compró pero que llevó a que muchos
franceses votarán por él porque
compraban su propuesta en vez de la
propuesta que ofrecía marine lepén los
convencía más y por eso él fue uno de
los puntos coyunturales de la campaña y
de los debates será un gobierno enfocado
en la recuperación económica será un
gobierno destinado a pensar netamente en
francia- y olvidar un poco fuera de las
fronteras del país que perspectiva tiene
usted yo pienso que la primera
perspectiva que podemos tener es una
perspectiva de después es la inflación
de tener una una nueva dinámica por
sobre todo por las pymes franceses que
también fueron muy impactadas durante
esta pandemia y creo que durante esos
discursos y esta campaña el presidente
manuel macrón candidato
hablo mucho a estos a este sector a esos
pymes para hablar justamente de relanzar
la economía y que ahora como como
relanzar la economía eso es una una
buena pregunta porque yo creo que
también lo vemos que ahora se habló
durante sus últimos últimas semanas de
la energía que también cuenta mucho
también en europa y en el caso de
francia de de saber cómo también tener
una una nueva dinámica una nueva
política tanto todo el líbero europeo
que también exterior francés y también
otras perspectivas que es muy importante
en la perspectiva de decir que que
emanuel macro también tiene que ayudar
bastante al
las personas que no que no tenían la
fuerza mente un suelto sus la gente para
para tener otras oportunidades
oportunidades laborales y también
oportunidades en libia para vivir mejor
y eso creo que es muy importante son dos
perspectivas tanto al nivel europeo y el
nivel nacional que además que tratar de
relanzar la economía de un país cuando
el mundo entero está tratando de
relanzar la economía no va a ser fácil
ingresar a los mercados cuando todo el
mundo quiere levantar la economía al
mismo tiempo francia tampoco lo va a
tener fácil
a nivel europeo jan cuál es su
perspectiva este liderazgo que tiene que
tener francia ya pasó la era merkel
donde alemán era como el motor que
jalonaban la unión europea se enfrentan
ahora a un escenario muy complicado con
rusia a la vuelta de la esquina
en ucrania en una guerra que la gente
pensaba que iba a durar poco que los
mismos rusos pensaron que iba a durar
poco y parece que sea prolongar más de
lo esperado cómo será ese escenario
europeo que el liderazgo tiene que jugar
francia y si después en mayo el macro es
realmente está muy comprometido con el
tema lo ha dicho durante toda su campaña
entonces la va a jugar mucho con el tema
europeo además estamos todavía en la
presidencia francesa hasta hasta el fin
de este semestre entonces va a
aprovechar esta esta coyuntura para
tratar de hacer avanzar a muchas cosas
europa está en un punto realmente muy
muy importante por la guerra en ucrania
va a ver el tema de ampliar
eventualmente un poco más la unión
europea al este también de profundizar
sobre sobre distintos distintos temas
incluso temas de defensa no con la
amenaza rusa que se concreta hay muchas
cosas que discutir en europa y
seguramente que macro va a tener que que
tener un liderazgo hasta ahí sobre todo
que alemania que es más dependiente del
gas ruso digamos no no está ejerciendo
este este liderazgo en este momento
entonces macro hay tiene un espacio que
que ocupar ciertamente y qué temas
pueden pulsar en esa agenda más el tema
de defensa más el tema energético
o sea seguir siendo ese mandatario que
puede hablar con putin por teléfono como
no lo pueden hacer otros mandatarios y
ser tal vez un puente
para normalizar un poco la situación en
ucrania cual quiere usted y yo nos
detenemos mucho bueno lo puede hacer
solo no depende mucho de de cuál tipo de
alianza puede construir acá pero
seguramente hay ya hay muchos dossier
ahí que hay que impulsar de integración
bueno para para relanzar la economía en
parte pero sobre el tema energético
seguramente hay muchas iniciativas hay
que tener y seguramente tendrá algunas
iniciativas importantes por ahí y james
ya ya me quedan pocos minutos para
finalizar el programa quiero que nos
mantengamos en el tema internacional y
un tema importante las relaciones con el
otro lado del atlántico con américa
latina y con un país clave eeuu por
supuesto comencemos por por américa
latina la relación que puede
desarrollarse entre esta región y
francia para estos cinco años ha sido
cercana en cierta forma pero después de
la pandemia y precisamente en ese
despegar económico que perspectiva puede
haber para américa latina allí
yo puedo que yo que yo pienso que
emanuel macro entendió que no ha ido
bastante en américa latina tiene que ser
más conectados para américa latina
usted fue en el g20 en argentina pero el
próximo quinquenio que va a empezar va a
ser
una manera de relanzar la relación
fuerte que tiene diferencia con américa
latina y el carnet un primero porque ya
no hay que recordar que es una de las
más grandes de francia y porque también
tenemos una promiscuidad es muy fuertes
entre
francia y entre los países
latinoamericanos yo hablo por ejemplo de
en el caso de colombia en el caso
también de argentina y yo creo que es
hay una una cooperación que se hizo
desde 2014
acá en en francia con la con el día aquí
después fue una semana de américa latina
y del caribe y que tanto del otro lado
que ahora también hay una cooperación
cultural económica que se va a reforzar
porque de manuel macro con la cultura
que no fue fácil para él
va a tener que reforzar
uno de sus puntos que quiere desarrollar
claro y por este lado ya no relaciones
con américa latina y añadamos de una vez
washington porque se nos va acabando el
tiempo si a nivel macro es el presidente
de la globalización del mundial ismo
digamos del cosmopolitismo entonces si
hay un gobierno favorable a mejorar las
relaciones con eeuu con américa latina
pues seguramente será el suyo pero yo
creo que esto depende también en muchas
cosas en la coyuntura internacional
también de la de la
tendencia que van a tener los gobiernos
en américa latina el libre comercio y
los grandes tratados digamos comerciales
ya haya ya no son tan populares entonces
hay que ver el sobre sobre esto es lo
que se puede hacer y bueno sobre otros
terrenos de cooperación seguramente
habrá cosas que construir no podemos
dejar de mencionar china que también es
un actor importante a nivel
internacional rápidamente para el cierre
ya
china
con respecto a francia digamos si es
evidentemente un país que cuenta cada
vez más pero también en este mundo en
mensaje o política que se redibuja las
relaciones con la entre china y rúsia
pues hay muchas incertidumbres acá
entonces hay que ver realmente cómo va a
evolucionar esto no es es un poco
difícil pero no no no se sabe muy bien
si vamos a ir en otro momento de
globalización o hacia la constitución de
nuevos bloques y eso es algo que va
mucho más allá diferencia me quedan 40
segundos para finalizar el programa
hagamos rápidamente las conclusiones
guillem que deja toda esta jornada
electoral que deja este inicio del nuevo
mandato del presidente marcó su
perspectiva general su conclusión
mi conclusión es decir que es una
oportunidad yo creo por
porque manuel macrón como gobernante de
demostrar dt de cambiar para entre
comillas para retomar sus sus palabras
de cambiar las visiones y yo creo que
eso dependerá mucho de la coyuntura y
dicen y que bueno siempre sobre
cualquier área una victoria tan grande
no de una victoria tan grande de una
victoria misma y jan para el cierre de
10 segundos si una francia que retrasa
de nuevo la extrema derecha pero pues
con cada vez más divisiones y cada vez
más dificultades políticas para hacerlo
bueno pues si tienen ustedes el análisis
tienen los retos que va a enfrentar
francia a partir de este nuevo mandato
estos nuevos cinco años en los que
manuel más con va a estar al frente de
este país europeo ya veremos cómo se
desempeña y qué logros obtiene a lo
largo de estos cinco años las tareas son
difíciles ustedes puede seguir dejando
sus comentarios en las redes sociales a
través de instagram twitter y facebook
sigan con nosotros
[Música]